E aí
[Aplausos]
e eu venho de uma família de advogados
paz advogados avô Juiz de Direito e
diversos parentes também nesse âmbito
jurídico só para vocês terem uma ideia
quando eu era pequeno Eu nunca ficava de
castigo eu ficava sub judice e quando eu
fazer alguma coisa errada eu não era
mandado para casa de minha avó eu era
Deputado Isso é só para vocês terem uma
noção de como jargões jurídicos eles
faziam parte da minha criação eu ainda
abrigo que se na minha família se você
saco de uma árvore cai 10 advogados Pois
é pessoal na prática quando nós somos
ainda muito jovens nós somos
confrontados com a pergunta social que
tem um peso absurdo nas nossas vidas mas
muito de nós não conseguimos perceber
isso a simples pergunta o que você vai
ser quando crescer essa pergunta é muito
forte e aí uma certa feita quando eu já
estava trabalhando como office-boy
inclusive um dos meus pais minha mãe
olhou no fundo dos meus olhos e falou
assim vejo em você um excelente advogado
pronto estava ali formado mais um
advogado na família eu olhava para o
lado via todos os meus parentes fazendo
aquilo eu não tinha medo de trabalho
então qualquer coisa que fosse para
poder conseguir
rentabilizar eu conseguiria trabalhar
via que o escritório tinha honorário
significativos não estava ali traçado
meu caminho e acabei fazendo a mesma
coisa que os lobos jovens fazem Cá Sem
junto com a minha matilha então há dez
anos eu me tornei um advogado
bem-sucedido
eu tinha nesse momento uma uma visão
equivocada do que era ganhar dinheiro do
que era uma profissão eu achava que
profissão era algo que se fazer de
segunda a sexta-feira
o dinheiro para gastar no final de
semana
quanto equivocada eu estava de pensar
dessa forma Na verdade uma profissão ela
vai muito além de toda de toda essa
questão de somente gerar dinheiro o
dinheiro ele apenas um dos indicadores
que você está no caminho certo mas a
verdade uma profissão é uma oportunidade
que você tem de durante o seu dia
exercer por mais tempo seu propósito
então a gente acaba não percebido mas a
escolha pelo trabalho Ela é super
importante porque
muitos de nós acaba não entendendo não
conseguimos sentir isso mas a maioria de
nós uma hora no trabalho e dorme em casa
é mas aí eu pergunto para vocês e se
tirassem essa condição de médico de
professor de pedreiro de advogado de
dona de casa quem é você de verdade
indivíduo único do universo Você sabe
quem é
e quando alguém lhe me pergunta quem
você é você geralmente responde quando
me criatura da sua profissão é o que é
normal para a sociedade a pessoa
pergunta você fala eu sou um médico
Professor o pedreiro
e mais quem é você de verdade você sabe
quem você é
Oi e aí eu vou pedir permissão para
vocês agora para poder me apresentar
como eu me vejo hoje
Olá meu nome é Brandão Freire eu sou uma
pessoa que procuro todos os dias sem um
essencialista eu sou o pai de Lucas e
Fernanda sou um sujeito um rabo que
tenho muita satisfação em dizer que sou
casado com minha esposa e amada Adriana
eu sou uma pessoa que tem no meu
vocabulário as palavras empreender e
viver como sinônimos Tenho muito orgulho
de dizer que tenho Deus no meu coração e
o meu propósito é melhorar a qualidade
de vida das pessoas ao reconectar lascou
naturezas ajudando ainda as mesmas a
clarear em a respeito dos seus
propósitos
é sem dúvidas eu sou uma pessoa que vivo
diariamente o meu propósito Essa é minha
melhor definição
Mas o que eu queria trazer para vocês é
que eu entendo que
o propósito ele tem que ser vivido
diariamente você precisa encontrar o seu
propósito mas
é o que ocorre é que a sociedade ela
impõe uma série de competições e nós não
percebemos isso e todos os cantos você a
sociedade tenta fazer com que todos nós
sejamos iguais quando na verdade nós
somos pessoas diferentes
constante e completamente mutáveis o
maior exemplo disso foi a as Olimpíadas
de Tóquio que aconteceu alguns meses
atrás ao assistir às Olimpíadas nós
conseguimos perceber que diversas
modalidades tem um Biotipo preponderante
se você observar e Dificilmente uma
pessoa de baixa estatura ela vai se
destacar uma quadra de basquete assim
como uma pessoa que seja muito forte
pesada ela vai ter dificuldades em ser
um jóquei e fazer o seu cavalo tem um
melhor resultado em uma pista de hipismo
bom então não é que existam pessoas é
com uma determinada É sério determinadas
a exercer uma determinada atividade o
tipo de atividade mas a mesma a mesma
coisa acontece com as pessoas e suas
atividades profissionais nós possuímos
um perfil comportamental e faz com que
nós façamos uma determinada atividade
com muito mais facilidade ou não então é
necessário você analisar Quais são as
suas habilidades com as suas
competências Quais são as suas
limitações para poder você escolher uma
atividade e que você possa fazer isso
com muito mais facilidade o mundo como
eu falei não é que exista pessoas
determinadas a fazer atividades
pré-estabelecidas não é isso mas
e é com Biotipo é como lá na Olimpíada
se você tem certas habilidades Você vai
bater muito mais facilidade com
atividade a beoncé Eu gostei tanto desse
tema que também me formei
analista de perfil comportamental e
quando eu fiz essa formação eu consegui
compreender que todos nós somos muito
diferentes e essa é a beleza da coisa e
eu entendi também que nós não podemos
nivelar as pessoas pelo mesmo nível de
avaliação como bem diz Albert Einstein
Todos nós somos um gêmeos
é a diferença está justamente quando ele
fala que
e se você fizer avaliar um peixe pela
capacidade dele subir numa árvore ele
vai passar a vida toda achando que é um
estupro então se você parar para
analisar o macaco vai subir uma árvore
com velocidade incrível e quanto um
peixe ele não consegue fazer isso agora
se você botar um peixe para nadar ele
vai fazer essa atividade de uma maneira
infinitamente mais rápida do que um
macaco
bom então pessoal
a grande diferença está em você se
conhecer as pessoas elas muitas vezes
não sabem quem são não sabe de onde vem
ou então para onde vão o
autoconhecimento ele é de extrema
importância para poder você encontrar o
seu propósito então
é uma forma de você é levar esse nível
de
como é que eu vou dizer assim de
conhecimento e autoconhecimento é
justamente fazer analise Quais são as
atividades que lhe dão satisfação
pessoal Quais são as atividades que
fazem o que você desempenhem aquela
atividade de maneira
mais
fácil mas sem tantas dificuldades né
então assim não existe um caminho errado
existe o seu caminho a faculdade de
direito que eu fiz né porque depois eu
me tornei o jardineiro hoje se a
sociedade se foi pode me perguntar quem
você é eu for responder ao invés de como
eu respondi agora a pouco para o meu me
apresentei para vocês se eu for
responder para nomenclatura da minha
profissão eu sou um paisagista seu
jardineiro pessoa um advogado promovido
a dizer
bom então a faculdade de direito atrás
ela me foi o útil iogurte até hoje
eu fui lá que eu aprendi um professor de
Filosofia ao citarem Heráclito né
filósofo pré-socrático conhecido como o
pai da dialética que nenhum homem pode
se banhar duas vezes no mesmo Rio porque
da segunda vez o rio já não é mais o
mesmo tão pouco homem da mesma forma que
nas lições deixadas
pelo nosso conterrâneo e sabe o jurista
Rui Barbosa ao falar sobre a isonomia
quando ele dizia que a igualdade é
tratar desigualmente os desiguais
Então essas duas frases ela se completam
no sentido de que somos completamente
diferentes um dos outros e somos ainda
constantemente no tablet
bom então eu pergunto a vocês se somos
tão diferentes e mutáveis porque o
escolhemos uma profissão devemos
fazê-las para o resto de nossas vidas
onde tá inscritos
é o fato pessoal é que uma escolha uma
escolha profissional cada somente e
Recompensas materiais elas ela pode ser
um grande vilão de tempo e quanto uma
uma escolha com base em prazer e
satisfação pessoal ela pode alavancar a
sua carreira para estágios inimagináveis
Essa é a grande realidade
e nos dias atuais abrir mão do tempo que
já se gastou para poder percorrer um
outro caminho Pode parecer loucura pode
gerar medo e segurança na maioria das
pessoas
e mais o quê que acontece nessas
situações a comodidade faz com que as
pessoas peguem os seus sonhos e coloquem
como algo secundário
faz com que o status social e a
estabilidade
Gere muitas vidas rasas e superficiais
E é isso que acontece
Oi e o quê que acontece quando você
adaptar o seu perfil comportamental
para poder exercer uma atividade que não
está em sintonia com seu propósito
para poder você ser uma pessoa que não é
naturalmente você não é aquela pessoa
você gasta energia você gasta de dia
você chega no final do dia em casa
cansado
entender quem somos entender os nossos
pontos fortes e os nossos pontos fracos
faz com que a gente canalize a nossa
energia na direção do nosso foco e isso
é muito importante uma dica que eu dou
para vocês para poder ela levar ao seu o
seu estado a um nível maior de propósito
é fazer justamente uma análise inversa
analisar Quais são as atividades que
você tem prazer em fazer
e geralmente essas atividades elas vão
estar em sintonia com seu eu de verdade
mas como
e como ser feliz na vida
e como encontrar essa felicidade
vivendo de forma plena e como viver de
forma primeiro se encontrando o seu
propósito de vida e
é emitido que o propósito ele tem três
partes a primeira delas é você
compreender quem você é quais são as
habilidades e as suas limitações
investigam os seus valores entenda Quais
são as suas paixões
após compreender quais são essas paixões
Quais são os seus princípios passe a
viver de acordo com eles é inegociável
abrir mão dos seus princípios Esse é o
primeiro. O segundo. É quando você
ignora que a sociedade é competitiva
Imagine que não se critique pelo fato de
você estar dançando numa pista que
alguém pode falar mal que você não dança
bem tal o que você precisa fazer é
fechar os olhos deixar música entrar
pelos ouvidos correr toda a sua cabeça e
você dançar do jeito que você quiser não
aceite críticas
o metal fusion os seus ouvidos para isso
você é um indivíduo único então importa
como você vai estar dançando na pista o
que importa é que você vai estar se
divertindo já dizia Rua um dia mestre
das artes marciais que as competições
elas revelam as nossas fraquezas e
inflar o ego os nossos verdadeiros
oponentes somos nós mesmos
A óptica pela autenticidade e não pela
prova social
a autogestão ela também é
importantíssimo nesse processo de
melhora dizer não há atividades que não
estão no caminho do seu propósito elas
vão fazer também vou ser caminhar mais
na direção dele
e entenda Quais são as atividades que
lhe dão prazer e que paralelo a isso
fazem com que você consiga resolver um
problema um problema e que vai fazer com
que o mundo se torne o ambiente melhor
Imagina o quão quanto bacana você passar
e sentir que o mundo se tornou um lugar
melhor só porque você está lá
e paralelo a isso
e
nós poderíamos evoluir se nós não
tivéssemos um problema para poder
resolver isso seria muito difícil de ser
feito e é difícil sim eu sei que é
difícil
é mas a derrota é o nosso maior mestre
é um momento em que nós entendemos que
verdadeiramente somos e é na Vitória que
não deveríamos devemos nos sentir
superiores Não devemos nos sentir
soberbos nem melhores do que ninguém
e quando a gente
consegue achar o Nosso propósito O que
que a gente precisa fazer a gente achou
e a gente começa a viver com base nossos
princípios e aí a gente entra no
terceiro. O terceiro. Ele Visa você usar
todo esse conhecimento adquirido para
poder servir as pessoas
servir as pessoas para poder fazer com
que elas alcancem as suas melhores
versões
aí quando isso acontece a coisa se fecha
e você consegue sentir a magia da coisa
porque como eu falei das derrotas e das
Vitórias não existe uma uma limitação
para poder você viver isso a maior
tarefa termina no meu ponto de vista é
você compreender compreender quem você é
depois você faz a sua autogestão depois
você parte para si Oi e aí depois que
você vive isso todos os dias você tem a
missão de amplificar essa mensagem como
nós estamos fazendo aqui no Peri ficar
essa mensagem para um nível
extraordinário para que as pessoas
consigam saber que existe uma vida além
desse encontro em uma vida muito
prazerosa eu posso dizer isso para vocês
então eu eu peço de coração que quem
assiste Quem assiste esse momento que
possa é pelo menos ter compreendido que
a geração certa não é para frente e sim
para dentro a cada vez mais para dentro
dentro de nós mesmos
G1